and a Russian journalist has been killed
during shelling in southern Ukraine Ria
news agency reporter rosti slavsure of
blev was covering a story in a Frontline
Village in the zaparita region three
others were also injured in that attack
Russia's defense Ministry says Ukrainian
forces used cluster Munitions hitting
the vehicle that the journalists were in
well let's bring in Daniel Hawkins he
joins us from Moscow Daniel that's
really quite the claim there from the
Russians what more do we know about what
exactly happened there in zapparita
well the Russian Ministry of Defense
says this is and it took place around
midday local time in the zaporizo region
where fighting has been particularly
intense between Ukrainian and Russian
forces especially in the area around
where these this journalist was killed
we understand a group of Russian media
consisting of around nine reporters uh
was working when they were struck
according to the Russian defense
Ministry by cluster Munitions we
understand three other journalists were
injured one from real novelty and two
from the isvesti estate news agency
they're in a stable condition
was evacuated but tragically died on the
way to hospital was a highly experienced
War correspondent he'd been covering
this conflict since 2014 and had
actually been a volunteer Fighter for
the at the time self-proclaimed the next
Republic as well when these hostilities
broke out
um now there's been some Furious
reaction from Moscow from the Kremlin
regarding this incident Maria zacharva
spoke to one for Russian foreign
Ministries saying those responsible for
this incident will be held responsible
that means to Polansky who's Russia's
Deputy ambassador to the United Nations
saying that this attack has crossed all
moral red lines and Constantine
kosichoff device Deputy speaker of the
Russian Federation Council saying that
Ukraine and Washington bear equal
responsibility for this attack allegedly
as we say carried out by cluster
Munitions in this area Daniel you say he
was covering fighting there can you give
us an update on what's happening on the
front lines what are the Russians saying
now
well I've been particularly pitched
battles artillery battles in the zapore
Asia region where this incident took
place both sides at the moment are
trying to Target each other's supply
lines ammunition Depots deep behind the
front lines with rockets and artillery
um the Russian defenses according to the
Russian Ministry of Defense having
particularly challenged by Ukrainian
forces around the city of bakmut around
the areas of clichevka where Ukraine
forces have been trying to encircle the
Russian army in the city now over the
last several days now a lot of the
intention of course has been on the
Ukrainian counter-attack in this area
but the Russian forces according to the
Russian Ministry of Defense have
actually been on the attack in the
Northern areas of Donetsk and logansk
particularly around the town of kupensk
where the Russian forces say Russian
groups of assault assault combatants and
uh of Aviation have been trying to push
the Ukrainian forces away from those
forested areas around those towns in an
attempt to and move the front line away
from the borders of the logansk region
so very much a shifting situation over
the last 24 hours across those front
lines the latest news also coming in
that Ukrainian armed forces have
launched another offensive using Western
Weaponry Western tanks and armored
vehicles around the town of oriechov
also on the zapore Asia front with
anticipation from the Russian initial
defense that there will be a further
intensification of fighting in that area
in the hours and days to come Daniel
Hawkins there with the latest for us
from the Russian capital thank you
Daniel